2 et le deuxième témoignage du patron de
miss vienne qui n'est plus de la partie
voilà qui vont tous qui voit là étaient
pieds tel film à temps de dire à tort de
prendre tous les maux donc voilà je
raconte pas les gens comme ça comme des
télécoms des tul y voilà on les trouve
un bon moment après midi elle après lui
avoir alors est-ce qu'on peut être
qu'elle a c'est peut-être parce qu'on a
l'impression que oui en fait ça donc
c'était je pense qu'à la cla ses
préférés et puis après pour revenir aux
délégués de miss guyane
à noter que tous les délégués régionaux
sont bénévoles donc donne pour les
élections régionales
et donc je pense je me mets à sa place
et il doit vraiment être triste d'avoir
jean pascal il ya pas longtemps il avait
dit tout le mal qu'ils pensaient de sa
belle-soeur ce qu il m arrivait presque
presque marié avec la soeur de sylvie
tellier et c'est vrai qu'il avait plutôt
attaqué et il a voulu se rattraper dans
donnie dernier dans tpm paie encore en
lui envoyant en direct comme ça une
sorte de deux de ses affaires le
cessez-le-feu en israël et rabibochant
doxa elle a même pas des nutriments chez
nous pour avoir la même rendu à son
texto pour comprendre l aisne présidence
à vie elle est élue comment je comprends
pas très bien passé grande enquête et
production et donc elle fait bien les
choses quand même parce que si elle est
là c'est quand même une très bonne
présidente
alors il ya les analyses de nos people
t'expliquer sur les antennes que les
mesures sanitaires n'ont pas du tout été
respectée lors de l'élection miss midi
pyrénées
une miss a été testé positif sur que
derrière rien n'a été fait donc les
employés de miss france était soumis à
un grand danger regarde vite et les
halles a déclaré on continuera à prendre
toutes les mesures nécessaires sur les
élections régionales des jeunes femmes
ont testé les mesures barrières ont été
respectées aujourd'hui je suis en mesure
de vous affirmer que c'est faux tu as eu
le témoignage d'une miss qui a participé
à miss midi pyrénées elle est restée
pendant deux jours avec toutes les
autres filles elle a été exclue du
concours la veille de l'élection parce
qu'elle a été testée positive à la coved
sauf que qu'est-ce qui ce qu'il a fait
le comité régional il a exclu cette
fille mais il a laissé les autres entre
elles faire le concours avec les risques
de contaminer les maquilleurs les
stylistes qui entraîne la famille etc
voilà alors oui j'ai lu en fait comme
beaucoup d'élections régionales n'avait
pas eu lieu en raison de la pandémie se
sont précipités en septembre octobre
pour tout boucler et cette élection là
c'est vrai que miss ariège qu'elle même
est infirmière s'est déclarée positive
elle s'est retirée
et comme la préfecture n'a pas eu le
temps d'interdire le comité a dit allez
on essaye de passer on y va et le
protocole a été moyennement respectés
miss france aura lieu quand même le 19
décembre oui voilà c'est jean pierre
foucault qui va présenter sur l'humain
ce sera la 100e et gilbert est ce que
vous avez d'autres infos si vous voulez
on peut voir quelques messages qui
étaient autour du groupe axa qui est la
taupe ils allaient messaline et les
messages qui sont dans le groupe wanted
l'app store voilà oui il est vraiment
bien placé là tout le sel vous êtes dans
le groupe axa alors c'est sylvie tellier
donc on a regroupé un jeune elle dit à
toutes les miss parce qu'elle en a marre
elle pète les plombs
je regrette que vous n'arriviez pas à
analyser un projet dans sa globalité la
prochaine fois je serai un album panini
fois une miss qui dit ça m'étonnerait
que l'éditeur dit je les veux tout point
sauf laetitia et rachel legrain-trapani
ce que sylvie tellier a dit c'est
l'éditeur ce n'est pas moi c'est faux
c'est elle qui décide de tout quand elle
veut décider halde et sierre soleil
c'est en tout cas gilles verdez pour
toutes ces infos rachelle par bojan foot
tout ça mais vous savez quand même à la
cérémonie miss france ou non non non je
vous avais pas envie de voir dieu non
mais ça on le dit on n'est pas envie de
voir la gueule de sylvie tellier
en fait c'est ça ma brand touchés
je vais pas encore mais pas envie de
voir ça